dernière vérification pour apolline et
célestine ces deux étudiantes
bourguignonne se sont lancé un défi
participer au 4l trophy un aller-retour
de 6000 kilomètres dont une bonne partie
en plein désert marocain
je suis très d'aventurière la seule
petite appréhension qui pourrait avoir
oui c'est une casse mécanique
éventuellement par contre cette aventure
elle repose quand même beaucoup sur le
côté solidarité
donc je compte évidemment sur les
objectifs la justice est vraiment un
problème est qu'on n'arrive pas à le
résoudre une ou deux
les frangines ont racheté la 4l à
d'anciens participants mais elle va
encore être soumise à rude épreuve
heureusement apolline et célestine font
équipe avec des élèves du lycée camille
du gast de chalon sur saône spécialisé
en contrôle technique
ils vérifient les points
particulièrement vulnérables aux sables
les frères plus important parce que
c'est les sabran demain samedi 8 au
moteur tout ce qui est
fait le trac sens on va dire aussi parce
que si c'est mal me piquer des choses
qui coule en contrebas ya plus de
voitures
on a aussi bas essayer de mémoriser des
petites astuces par exemple s'il ya un
de la surchauffe dans le moteur va
allumer le chauffage à fond pour essayer
de refroidir le moteur
voilà et puis après on essaie pas trop
pousser la 4l donc faire des postes-clés
deux hommes dans ce raid sans chrono ce
qui motive les frangines c'est le côté
humanitaire du 4l trophy
plus de mille participants emporte des
fournitures scolaires et des dons
destinés aux écoles les plus démunis au
maroc
bah ya beaucoup à 6 2 devant financiers
qui sont donnés aux écoles du maroc qui
permettent notamment la construction
d'écoles supplémentaire au maroc et ça
enfin moi c'est non ce serait ma plus
grande fierté si on pouvait amener notre
pierre à l'édifice
c'est une expérience qui va être très
enrichissante sur le plan personnel on
va distribuer du matériel scolaire aux
enfants donc il ya même plus beau et
puis visité le maroc ça ça va vraiment
être fun apolline et célestine partiront
ce lundi en convoi avec huit autres
équipages de bourgogne franche comté
l'ensemble des participants quitteront
biarritz le 20 février
arrivé du 4l trophy si tout va bien le
28 à marrakech
[Musique]